so we have a type of statistical study
described here i encourage you to pause
this video read it and see if you can
figure out is this a
sample study is it an observational
study is it an experiment and then also
think about what type of conclusions can
you make based on the information in the
study
all right now let's work on this
together
british researchers were interested in
the relationship between farmers
approach to their cows and cow's milk
yield they prepared a survey
questionnaire regarding the farmer's
perception of the cow's mental capacity
the treatment they give to the cows and
the cow's yield
the survey was filled by all the farms
in great britain
after analyzing their results they found
that on farms where cows were called by
name
milk yield was 258 liters higher on
average than on farms when this was not
the case all right so they're making a
connection between two variables one was
whether cows called by name
whether
whether cow's named all right whether
cows
named
and this would be a categorical variable
because for any given farmer it's going
to be a yes or no that the cows are
named and so they're trying to form a
connection between whether the cows are
named and
and milk yield
and this would be a quantitative
variable because you can you're
measuring it in terms of number of
liters
milk milk
yield whether
we are drawing a connection
and they're able to draw some form of a
connection they're saying hey when the
cows were called by name milk yield was
258 liters higher on average than on
farms when this was not the case
so first let's just think about what
type of statistical study this is and we
could think okay is this a sample study
is this a sample study is this an
observational study
observational
or is this an experiment
now a sample study
an experiment
a sample study you would be trying to
estimate a parameter for a broader
population
here it's not so much that they're
estimating the parameter they're trying
to see the connection between two
variables
and that brings us to observational
study because that's what an
observational study is all about can we
draw a connection can we draw a positive
or negative correlation between
variables based on observations so we've
surveyed a population here the farmers
in in great britain and we are able to
draw some type of
connection between these variables
and so this is clearly an observational
and observational study now this this is
not an experiment if there was an
experiment we would take the farmers and
we would randomly assign them into one
or two groups
and in one group we would say don't name
no name
no naming and in the other group we
would say name your cows
and then we would wait some period of
time and we will see the average milk
production going into the experiment in
the no naming group and the naming group
and then we will see we wait some period
of time six months a year and then we'll
see the average milk production
after either not naming or naming the
cows for six months so that's not what
occurred here here we just did the
survey to everybody and we just asked
them this question and we were able to
find this we were able to find this
connection between whether the cows were
named and the actual milk yield so
clearly not an experiment this was an
observational
study now the next thing is what can we
conclude here we know when you know
they're telling us that when the cows
were named it looks like there was a
258 liter higher yield on average
so the conclusion that we can strictly
make here is like well
for
farmers in great britain there is a
correlation a positive correlation
between whether cows are named and the
milk yield so that we can say for sure
so let me write that down
so for great britain for
four great britain farmers
great britain
farmers
we have a positive correlation
positive correlation
between naming cows
between
naming
cows
and milk yield
and
milk yield
that's pretty much what we can say here
now some people might be tempted to try
to draw causality you'll see this all
the time where you see these
observational studies and people try to
hint and maybe there's a causal
relationship here maybe the naming is
actually what makes the milk yield go up
or maybe it's the other way the cows
produce a lot of milk the farmers like
them more and they want to name them
because like hey that's my high milk
producing cow
so
there's a lot of there's there's a lot
of temptation to say cow you know naming
that maybe there's a cause out of that
naming causes more milk
more milk
or that maybe more milk causes naming
you the farmers really like that cow so
they they start naming them or or
whatever whatever it might be
but it's you can't make this causal
relationship based on this observational
study you might have been able to do it
with a well-constructed experiment but
not with an observational study and
that's because there could be some
confounding variable that is driving
both of them so for example that
confounding variable might just be
a nice farmer
a
nice farmer and you know we can define
nice in a lot of ways they're gentle
they
and a nice farmer is more likely to name
and a nice farmer is more likely to get
is gets a higher yield and the reason
why this is a confounding variable if
you were to control for that if you just
take well let's just let's just control
for nice farmers and then see if naming
makes a difference it might not make a
difference if the if the farmer is you
know petting the cows and treating them
humanely and doing other things it might
not matter whether the the
whether the farmer names them or not
likewise if you take some less nice
farmers
who you know hit their cows and and they
they have really inhumane conditions it
might not make a difference whether they
name the cows or not and so it's very
important that you from the
observational studies you might if
they're well constructed you might be
able to make a a you might be able to
say there's a correlation but you it's
you won't be able to make a drive a
causal or make a causal conclusion